bonsoir naji bazerghi merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une
première réaction à ces deux auditions
tout d'abord oui écouter yale en tout
cas bonsoir et merci pour votre
habitation ce soir donc c'est un sujet
qui effectivement montre à quel point le
gouvernement aujourd'hui essaye
absolument de faire des effets d'annoncé
par rapport au bilan catastrophique que
nous sommes tous en train de de
constater ces deux dernières années
c'est un bilan catastrophique et dans
lequel le gouvernement tente un
échappatoire en essayant effectivement
d'un calvaire qu'on appellerait l'ordre
républicain qui ne veut dire en réalité
pas grand chose et qui clairement n'est
pas quantifiable
l'indicateur qui lui par contre devrait
intéresser tout le monde c'est l'
indicateur sur le chômage sur la santé
sur sur l'égalité et une sur des choses
en tout cas qui sont beaucoup plus
cartésienne
or là effectivement nous avons un
gouvernement qui nous pond une nouvelle
loi rallonge dans lequel effectivement
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont dit de
ci de là mais qui en réalité sont
beaucoup d'actes effet d'annonce et qui
en réalité ne sanctionne enfin tout ce
qui est tout ce qui est dit quasi
quasiment aujourd'hui par rapport à
l'apologie du terrorisme par rapport à
la citation la haine sont déjà des
choses qui sont dans leur grande mesure
déjà appliquée est applicable depuis
depuis longtemps donc on sent bien
qu'aujourd'hui on a un gouvernement qui
est aux abois
parce que en termes de chômage c'est une
catastrophe en termes de sur la crise
sanitaire on est frappé de nouveau par
une deuxième vague et on voit bien que
face à ça le gouvernement n'a rien mis
en place
on empêche peut-être pas l'autre il y à
des études assez régulière dans une
récemment qui pointe le recul de la
laïcité notamment dans les
établissements scolaires ça ne
correspond pas à la réalité selon vous
les études y en a beaucoup qui sont
faites dans une étude donc on peut leur
dire un peu tout et même son inverse
en réalité aujourd'hui on peut constater
alors j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses
j'ai entendu ces derniers temps que je
pense que vous l'avez également vous
remarqué j'ai entendu un ministre de
l'intérieur qui était choquée par les
rayons falaise j'ai été aussi frappé de
voir que aujourd'hui on a dissout des
organisations des ong des collectifs qui
luttait contre la discrimination sous un
motif qui est effectivement celui de la
lutte contre le terrorisme la
radicalisation or ces fermetures n'ont
aucun rapport avec leurs chefs
d'accusation donc effectivement on dit
beaucoup de choses on entend beaucoup de
choses mais dans la réalité
effectivement sous pas vraiment de la
réalité de ce que vivent les français
on est à même loin de ce constat
effectivement extrêmement une dernière
question vous reprend le chai à droite
vous le savez votre communautarisme
en tout cas le double micro parti que
vous êtes
est ce que vous avez eu votre mot vous
avez été associé aux discussions avec
les responsables musulmans sur ce projet
de loi
j'ai le sentiment plutôt que les
responsables musulmans sont aujourd'hui
traités par notamment par l'exécutif un
peu comme hôte encore une fois des
colonies c'est à dire qu'on essaye
effectivement de faire de l'ingérence au
lieu d'essayer de travailler avec
aujourd'hui les partenaires de la
communauté musulmane
les responsables d'autres cas vu du
culte musulman aujourd'hui on demande
effectivement une labellisation des
dégâts d'image entend donc beaucoup de
choses
et effectivement les accusations les
éléments de langage qui consiste à nous
qualifier de communautariste parce
qu'ils le sont en réalité eux
de façon beaucoup plus manifeste je
pense à une certaine de droite dure
voire avec des médias au logis très
proche de l'extrême droite
je pense que voilà on est effectivement
des opposants politiques et à ce titre
là il va de soi qu'on parle nous coller
plusieurs étiquettes en réalité vu des
mèches n'est pas un parti de
communautariste quelques certains
entendent où on est justement le rempart
contre le séparatisme
nous sommes là pour méditer pour une
république qui puisse respecter et puis
surtout à protéger chaque citoyen est
pratiquée et toutes les personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui diffamer discréditer en
fonction de l'heure de leur patronyme
fonction de lourds de la croyance avérés
ou supposés
merci à jean guy d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france